a day after puerto rico's most powerful
earthquake in more than a century it's
not clear when the tremors will stop the
6.4 magnitude quake leveled buildings
and killed at least one person leaving
more than 300 people homeless late last
night the President signed an emergency
disaster declaration for the island our
lead national correspondent David Begg
know is imp own sake Puerto Rico David
what are you hearing well Anthony look
at what yesterday's quake did here in
Ponce a literally cause cracks and
splits in the earth you can put a foot
in this crack and probably go down about
4 to 5 feet here look there were more
earthquakes last night we felt them and
the threat of more quakes is what drove
people out of their homes a lot of
people slept in their cars and actually
on the street here in the ponse area but
this morning we're going to take you to
gwanak ax which was arguably the hardest
hit area as we walk down a Main Street
in Guanajuato Rico arguably the hardest
hit area this is what we saw downed
power lines
buildings reduced to rubble cars crushed
beneath crumbling foundations it looked
as though some areas had been bombed I
don't know like something exploded
we found Samantha Cortes and her family
at the shelter set up outside the gwanak
a Coliseum they're among the thousands
of people who fled their homes Tuesday
when the earthquake hit heading to
higher ground fearing a tsunami first
responders were handing out water they
provided medical care and dispersed cots
for the hundreds of people who slept
here overnight these are people who
either don't have a home to go home to
or they feel safer outside than they do
in their own home because they've been
dealing with earthquakes as one woman
told me almost every hour it felt like
for the last seven days I know it's in
anything like this never Felix Rodriguez
was watching over a neighbor when we met
him not far away Rosalie Torres kept her
two and five-year-old children close we
woke up and we've been throwing around
everything was shaking back and forth
back off everybody was people falling
back down boom and then it started
shaking everybody started screaming
people in the floor Torres's
mother-in-law told us that the family
just finished repairing the damage to
their home that was caused by Hurricane
Maria two and a half years ago and now
they will be forced to repair the home
again really we don't have no place to
stay because will house collapse your
house collapsed it went to the side
I lost everything look there's a lot of
rumor that's causing confusion here
namely that fracking may be causing this
earthquake that is not the case we
reached out to seismologists in the US
Department of Energy who tell us there
is no fracking on the island of Puerto
Rico are off the coast Porto Rico sits
on a complicated plate boundary what's
happening here is expected scientists
say and it may take a while for the
earth to just settle down
Tony boy David that fissure right there
that crack in the earth really tells the
story thank you very much
you